chocolat noir si vous avez à la viola
lapinous des lapins d'hérisson ou encore
des mésanges le chocolat va une nouvelle
fois ravir les papilles de toutes les
familles
on va fêter pâques en comité restreint
donc je vais en donner une partie sur la
chasse aux oeufs puis je vais envoyer
une partie aussi dans l'oise puisque
j'ai certains devaient nièce qui sont
malheureusement confiné ma grande fille
ne pourra pas venir puisqu'elle habite
en région parisienne donc elle n'a pas
droit de changer de région donc je vais
lui envoyer un petit colis par la poste
pour qu'elle reçoive quand même ses
chocolats une voiture faite en banane un
avocat transformer en sous marin une
carotte en forme d'avion
à défaut de pouvoir voyager ce
chocolatier invite à l'évasion
gustatives
cette année ben c'est vrai que l'on
travaille très bien à ce que quelque
part on profite malheureusement aussi
que les restaurateurs soient fermés que
les théâtres les cinémas soit fermée
donc le seul plaisir qui reste aux gens
aujourd'hui se faire plaisir c'est
devenir chef chocolatier pâtissier et ce
plaisir
il est le fruit de deux mois de travail
pas que représente 20% du chiffre
d'affaires du chocolatier
alors après le démoulage sébastien
papillon et ses douze artisans ont le
souci du détail
moi ce que j'aime en chocolat c'est
justement ce côté qu'on peut aimer de
brillance mais aussi on peut le patine
est donc là pour avoir un côté très
réaliste des animaux errants fait
ressortir les détails on vient le patine
et juste avec du cacao en poudre
donc voilà ici on achemine les produits
finis et ensuite ils sont conditionnés
par les jeunes filles et ensuite vont
partir dans les une deux trois boutiques
depuis près de 15 ans le chocolatier
propose des compositions réalisées avec
des produits locaux et une fois ce
week-end de pâques passé il imaginera
déjà les petites douceurs de 2022